martha's vineyard cheered for the
illegal immigrants as they shipped them
out of their community to cape cod after
50 of them arrived from florida but why
didn't celebrities like the obamas open
up their homes on martha's vineyard to
house them the former president and
several other high-profile democrats who
own homes are remaining silent other
residents were in a frenzy over the
migrants arrival last week but didn't
want to house them
i worry that people say hey they said
these people put them on this venue
no we didn't get rid of them we took
care of them okay okay getting rid of
them is a little harsh
you know this is not
like the best place for them to start
fresh because
there's no place to live here there's
like housing is bad and there's more
vacation homes here than anywhere in
america fifty-five percent of the home
fair vacation
and while the democrat mayor from el
paso continues to send migrant buses to
new york and doesn't get criticized the
democrat mayor from new york city is
slamming governors abba and desantis for
not coordinating with him even though he
turned down invitations to go see the
conditions at the border for himself
it is time for us to coordinate i
believe it's a crisis that needs more
coordination for from our country of you
know this is one country they refuse to
do any form of coordination we should do
it in a coordinated method coordination
during a crisis is something that we
must do together and that's the federal
government that are that is also
the governor of the state of texas as
well as the governor governor of the
state of florida we should not be
really treating other cities and
municipalities in the manner that we're
witnessing now
well i think one of the most impressive
things in that interview is how many
times he said coordinated but you know
anita i want to start with you first of
all i think michael goodwin put it very
well in the new york post recently he he
essentially said they're calling out the
democrats hypocrisy and what he said was
in quote by transporting migrants gop
governors are exposing democrats
hypocrisy that's the title the dems
running with new york chicago washington
dc and yes martha's vineyards are being
hoisted on their own petard they
supported virtually unfettered
immigration but didn't bargain on
thousands of the world's unwashed
popping up in their neighborhoods their
hypocrisy is the thing to behold and the
gop governors deserve an award for
delivering a comeuppance for the ages
now you know it is interesting anita
because if you go back to about 2016 uh
former president obama who has a very
lovely vacation home in martha's
vineyard this is what he had to say
about immigration take a listen
america is a nation of immigrants
that's our strength
and the notion that
somehow we would stop now
on what has been a tradition of
attracting
talent and strivers and dreamers from
all around the world
uh
that would
rob us of the thing that is most special
about america
so immigration and immigrants are very
special to america and president obama
likes to tweet about a lot of things
that he finds important he tweets about
the inflation reduction act about
overturning of roe he tweeted about the
queen's death but we have heard nothing
on immigration especially as these
migrants have gone to where he has a
vacation home why not yeah that's a
really good question he does love to
talk about immigration and jason and i
were talking earlier about how really
this how this free flow of immigrants
across the border started during his
administration but the interesting thing
about martha's vineyard is of all the
celebrities that have homes there and we
showed them on the screen his is
particularly interesting he has a 12
million dollar sprawling estate and
remember just last year he had a huge
birthday bash for himself remember when
he turned 60 and he had so many guests
and this was sort of during kobit that
he had to scale back the number of
guests because he was getting criticized
for having too many so it's interesting
uh there was
one person who spoke to the daily mail
who lives on martha's vineyard and she
told the paper that she felt that obama
should open up his home to some of these
immigrants as she pointed out though
when she went to visit his house this is
what she saw she said there were signs
that said private property no
trespassing do not come in and the
police are patrolling so i guess the
immigrants didn't feel too welcome over
there i mean i'm sure he has like one or
two guest guest rooms in that house what
about his front lawn
we can put up a 10 i guess right tyrus
so tyrus mayor oscar lisa he's a
democratic mayor of el paso texas
he's talking about sending migrants to
new york take a listen to what he had to
say
the people are not coming to el paso
they're coming to america
and that's something that's really
important we have about 50 percent of
the people today that do not have a
sponsor they don't have money so we're
helping and working to get them to where
they want to go
so tyrus you have the mayor saying we're
going to ship the people to new york
city that's where they want to go you
have mayor adams of new york city saying
let's coordinate let them come here but
tyrus one thing is the homelessness
crisis of new york city has reached an
all-time high one that hasn't been seen
since the great depression of the 1930s
just this summer you had about 52 000
homeless people in new york city alone
17 000 of them children don't you think
mayor adams should focus on the people
who elected him to represent him instead
of focusing on some of these more
political moves no because it's a lot
easier to fight the invisible monster
and i think in defense of the
celebrities at martha's vineyard they
were staffed up already so you it's the
off season so they were already staffed
so they're of course they didn't have
any any room for the other and i just
like to say to the lady who was saying
there was no place for them to live she
was literally standing in front of six
tenths there was six tents in hotels all
on that street where she was selling
goods to taurus so just want to put out
out there but uh yeah of course he
should be doing something but when you
there's a little i'm learning this i'm
learning the more and more i'm on tv the
more i study politics all you really
have to do is say something three times
and then it doesn't matter what the
question is so like you know coordinate
you on the chord because when i think
coordinate i'm talking about the inside
but see how that coordinated that with
this that's coordination
that's how you coordinate i'm
coordinated so i think he meant the same
thing like we all need to coordinate who
you won't go coordinate a trip
to texas to see what they're talking
about you won't coordinate anything for
the homeless people so i don't think he
understands what the word coordinate
means other than because everyone knows
he's a sharp dresser because all those
events he likes to go to the brother is
always coordinated yeah well tires but
one thing though you don't hear anybody
criticizing the democratic el paso mayor
for sending migrants out is that i mean
is it because he's a democratic mayor
because for some reason the republican
governors
are getting highly criticized because of
it well it's because he's coordinating
and see when you coordinate
there's no reason to be aggressive
unlike the republicans we're not
coordinating see he's coordinated and he
started his sentence with i'm a democrat
so therefore it's fine what he's doing
he's fine again i know i feel like i
just said this yesterday who started the
bussing and flying
party
biden's administration did so when their
own do it it's coordination and when we
do it it's racist tyrus's teaching roots
are coming out he's schooling all of us
here right now
coordinating some knowledge
jason i want to come to you right about
right now about half of the migrants
that are coming over illegally are being
shipped back under title 42. however
title 42 can end at any point right now
because that was implemented under the
trump administration because of the
coveted pandemic emergencies at any
point the cdc can pull back that state
of emergency and title 42 can be gone
and they're no longer able to send back
half of those migrants what is something
congress can do can they do anything to
fix it congress can do a lot of things
they can start by holding a hearing uh
jerry nadler is the chairman of the
judiciary committee where immigration
subcommittee is why not halt the hearing
i mean this is obviously a big issue no
hearings that are there democrats say oh
they just need to you know pass
comprehensive immigration reform well
the democrats have the house and senate
and the presidency for goodness sake but
if you hear and listen to kamala harris
she says the border's secure so if the
border's secure why do we have so many
illegal immigrants coming into this
country and shame on president obama who
goes out there and says oh we're going
to shut off immigration nobody
republicans democrats nobody has ever
suggested we cut off immigration what
we've said is cut off illegal
immigration come through the front door
do it legally and lawfully and how about
the people that are trying to do it
legally and lawfully those people get
screwed in this process we bring about a
million people a year legally and
lawfully into the united states he knows
better than to suggest that republicans
want to get rid of immigration we want
to get rid of illegal immigration all
the drugs that are flowing all the human
trafficking that's going on that the the
abuse of these people and to suggest
that going to martha's vineyard is like
abuse and human trafficking and and that
they should be suing these governors
come on gavin newsom you know better as
well if they involved in this rhetoric
and if it's an issue
have a hearing well introduce democrats
have never introduced since i joined
congress in 2008 they've never rallied
behind one bill that says this is what
we stand for do that before the election
i dare you because america is not behind
where they are on immigration it's just
a lack of coordination is what it is
well i think what it comes down to
president obama was correct that america
is made up of immigrants but it needs to
be legal immigration and not illegal
immigration and that is something that
is going to be on the ballot for
midterms coming up so your vote counts
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else